allora grazie essendo seguito anche io
da un pubblico molto giovane e
necessario che io faccia dei video che
rimangono alle persone che mi seguono
quindi oggi siamo qui su slate il
videogioco dove devi rubare alle persone
bestie youtuber 2016 tracce ci sono
anche un sacco di livelli se tutorial
home invasion dove devi rubare in casa
bank la banca the collector non so cosa
sia lo yacht mansion che la casa più
grossa e poi diamond list dovete di
rubare un diamante allora partiamo con
la prima anzi noi tuttavia non lo
facciamo perché io sono studiato su come
rubare le cose come invece non partiamo
subito con ladrata in casa vediamo se
riesco a fare qualcosa di decente io che
sono esperta l'altro c'è anche la vita è
la madonna ho parcheggiato davanti alla
vecchia bellissimo prima cosa da fare
ragazzi quando ci derubano le persone
bisogna parcheggiare la macchina davanti
al vialetto così che non si vede proprio
che ho parcheggiato anzi proprio tutto
stealth unit 50.000 dollari a provare
50.000 dollari precisi a va bene dei
ragazzi allora partiamo subito con
l'entrare in casa la prima cosa che deve
fare un lato quando arriva davanti alla
casa in questione citofonare il
campanello ed a tutti i cristiani non
sanno manco al campanello che cazzo da
non avere 50 mila dollari in casa la
porta è chiusa ma me l'aspettavo quindi
no problem altro modo di entrare in casa
potrebbe essere la finestra che non si
apre quindi niente dovrà trovare un
altro modo ancora il garage non si apre
manco il garage allora proviamo con la
porta sul retro stessa roba ci sono
delle leve in un'asta benissimo ragazzi
se trovate una scatola con dentro delle
leve tiratele che non si sa mai perfetto
mica lupin può accompagnare solo che
ladro studiato sono ragazzo è mica salve
le deve essere proprietari guardi lo ha
aperto la porta del garage
qualcosa mi dice che non gli sto
simpatico però non ne sono sicuro e mi
chiedo salve volevo presentarmi però
sono morto quindi non posto credo che il
tizio fosse il proprietario di casa ne
sono quasi sicuro il problema non è
quello il problema perché mi ha sparato
addosso a sangue freddo potevo essere
tipo fa vj passione elettricista che
magari stava aggiustando il quadro
elettrico che ne sai
ah ok e tipo una scassinare le porte
allora 00 32 e che sarà tipo 1 2 3 2 2 1
e 12 porta a porta non sbaglia tutti
allo 0 0 ma questo è arrivato tizio di
una conditio forza ema eva berdych ha
detto james fondi con la pistola cazzo
era affanculo c'ho provato dire alle
leve ragazzi niente non riesco a marco
entrare in casa c'è questo problema di
fondo se ne frega dai vieni vieni in
testa di cazzo di cavi addosso adesso
testa dico veloce
chiudi chiudi chiudi bene però spero
accetto che sto andando nel bagno il
bagno prefetto caccia la [ __ ] anzi
no errato sono incastrato in un bagno
questo potrebbe essere un problema posso
fuggire la quarta accesso accesso
scarica veloce scarica non si scale bene
sono già nel culo
devo usare qualcosa come arma cosa uso
come arma qui c'è una pistola iuso la
saponetta sei finito a testa di cazzo
abbiamo ce la porta in faccia veloce
sbattere la porta in faccia così minchia
lo store discoli stories colavita più
farmi chiara gallo sto stordendo è morto
quante sportellate gli ho dato è morto
dove sedime gli ho talmente dato tante
sportellate che si è dimenticato dov'ero
va bene spero e prego il dio che non
torni indietro però sono riuscito a
rifugiarmi in questa stanza tech tv
quale 200 dollari sta tv lettore dvd
poi mi spiegherei dovete le stai
mettendo ste cose perché anzi io un'idea
ce l'ho però vabbè documenti bancari
mi spieghi fratello perché tieni
documenti bancari sulla scrivania che
problemi hai al cervello
bene non so dove sia ma va bene così
tech tablet perfetto back doc mensa
ancora perfetto infatti documenti
bancari cia in casa spiega mentana non
mi ha visto la pista mi ha visto
qualcosa mi dice che mi ha visto però
non ne sono sicurissimo mazza da
baseball testa di cazzo mi piace stealth
sono l'inter se può accompagnare solo
bene
sono tornato qua c'era una cosa che
eccola perfetto cos'è sta roba bella la
cia prima che arrivi 53 42 lancio un
libro in bocca voglio dire come ridi poi
il sapere fa più male dei proietti di
testa di minchia minchia 6 risolto eri
morto fratello 53 42 ok 53 42 ricordiamo
e poi come minimo è il codice per aprire
il microonde però va bene ok di qua ma
che bella sta palla allora collective
del football miti a 750 dollari di paghe
cazzo di palla era trofei trofei prendi
tutto pre in tutto
ragazzi siamo a poco più di 5.600
dollari ma con questa roba qua 53 42
credo che almeno 50.000 ci arriviamo
speriamo fantastico miche 39 iv celi qua
dentro che eva 39.150 dollari mancano 10
mila dollari ci siamo ragazzi e cioè
niente sotto il letto c'è qualcosa porca
eva non come le vecchie che mettono i
soldi sotto ma la macchina vale come
cosa da rubare
perché se gli rubò la macchina sono a
posto ragazzi provo
a [ __ ] piace non posso fare la
macchina merda i cerchioni cerchioni
cazzo mi ha preso mi ha preso si veloce
veloce veloce chiudilo fuori dove devo
andare dove vado continueremo a sto
cazzo di vaso che a 10mila dollari di
maso veloce dai cazzo al grafico e senta
dollari rate non è che me li dai tu di
tasca tua già che ci sono andati sono
arrivato alla fine
ma dai ma [ __ ] la padella la
padella dai marra 160 dollari sto cazzo
di microonde il quadro perfetto veloce
veloce parkour italy infanzia passata a
guardare lupin mica cazzi qua ragazzi
miei avete appena visto come rubare
50.000 dollari nella più completa
tranquillità e segretezza d'accordo
ragazze dalla finora abbiamo scherzato
passiamo alle cose serie bank questa è
più cazzuta e me lo sento ma lei la
banca norman county bank va bene di un
id 500 a 500.000 qua giornate molto
piacere sono fa vj day rubare in questa
banca quando ne che mi presta il fucile
che così faccio la rapina
grazie norman county bank va bene allora
io come si ruba in banca permesso
buongiorno salve salve con giochi
dispiace se metto il culetto sulle sue
ginocchia meglio rimorchio così avete
solo allora devo andare a rubare ci
vediamo dopo se vuoi tanto è la madonna
c'è la fila ma che cazzo devi fare per
la fila per rubare non c'è non puoi
neanche rubare naturalmente un giorno
salve anche lei in fila perché deve
rubare è non esistono più i ladri di una
volta è che entra vi ruba ville ha preso
il numerino ruba prima lei poi robot io
mi scusi dovrei provare anch'io e non è
che possiamo metterci tutti in fila vi
date una mossa salve perché c'è un piano
di sopra tra l'altro ma chi cazzo ci fa
un piano di sopra per me salve a questa
è la consulenza su come rubare
fantastico tech monito sì perché se lo
prendo col tizio non mi spara per niente
in faccia senza dubbio guarda
porchia valeri la madonna a facciamo
tipo non è che posso tipo togliere la
corrente si stava trucchetto salve lei
fa la guardia i condotti da reazione no
perché non servivano tra l'atro se entro
in una porta a caso che magari ho
sbagliato ad aprire mi sparano in bocca
però se salto su una guardia
ovviamente non mi fa un cazzo anzi posso
usarlo anche come trampolino grazie
diciamo che saliva scalava ma come
faccio a derubare una banca senza
neanche un arma spiegatemi così sta roba
il cavo quattro tentativi perfetto e che
ne so io codice da qualche parte che
devo trovare che non so bene dove però
dove m chietti pista porta posso entrare
qua mi sparate addosso
posso entrare perfetto ma c'è un codice
nascosto che non sto vedendo ragazzi non
è che eccolo perfetto password a queste
sono le password mi scusi dov'è solo
scassinare il capo non mi spari è band
band veramente che buco del culo show
avuto su 13 tentativi il primo va bene
c'è solo un problema di fondo che
potrebbe essere alquanto spiacevole
mi scusi possono prendere questo piatto
che mi serve per capire se riesco a
eludere il sistema di sicurezza
ok il piatto passa il piatto è passato
in teoria dovrei passare anche io se la
fisica di questo gioco funziona
a quanto pare
cosa sta succedendo veloce merda e vabbè
è difficilissimo ragazzi però ce la
posso fare anche lunga ndola ma non è ma
che minchia si è aperto il portello e
[ __ ] non vale è scemo e scemo e
scemo 500.000 veloce non ci posso
credere che cazzo ci fa una cazzo di
guardia sul cazzo di tetto cosa ci fa
fosse tornato indietro è salito sul
tetto sto demente suicidi ti mio
grandissimo cosa ho fatto
[Musica]
44 secondi come fare una rapina in banca
in 44 secondi quale ragazzi allora per
oggi con chiudo qui con la rapina in
banca la prossima volta faccio the
collector dei ott
vediamo se esco a fare the man show
comunque sia per ora è fighissimo se
riuscisse a usare le armi sarebbe ancora
meglio perché magari non devo correre
come un disperato quindi la cassoli
spero che vi sia piaciuto come sette
minuti sul momento non mi piace ai
capace di facebook e cavani adottata
nelle scrizione sono divertiti siete lì
ci vediamo in un prossimo vito cela
ragazzi